there are many ways I can introduce this
next guest Pro Football Hall of Famer is
one I like that one Super Bowl champion
is another 11 time Pro Bowler is another
NFL Network compadre is another great
friend is another but I'm going to
introduce him in the way that I think
will delight him the most
because Rod Woodson I really appreciate
it now joining us here on the Rich Eisen
show only the only person at this desk
who's Alan Bonner beat Ohio State this
year Rod Woodson yeah on the Rich Eisen
show boiler up hammer down how about
that was that out of all the ways I
believe it introduced ah just to hunt
you like the introduction I love things
because I kind of clown myself just to
make no I know that's you know that was
a tough one you think ya know what
but it's no but you know one thing I'll
do love about Big Ten football's back
you know people at least we're playing
decent football around and we had some
arguments about being in the playoffs so
hopefully who's whose arguments about
being in the saying you know Big Ten
have been in in two years I know what
I'm saying we had arguments this year
about some Dr Haass baby in there okay
and but them losing tool to Purdue the
way they did right is the main reason
they're not in see now how do you take
it being obviously prideful for that
victory your coach was in demand
Louisville wanted him you know because
it's obviously that's where Brom went to
went to school and he stayed put and
there's a lot of prideful and and and
the way that they handled their business
that night Tyler Trent is just a
remarkable human being in a way that the
community surrounded him it was nothing
you should puff your chest out and yet
the whole conversation was you can't let
Ohio State in they lost to Purdue I know
that's I mean every show that I turned
on when they talked about a howl state
they just kept saying that you can't put
Ohio State any loss to Purdue right and
I'm like I was getting a little upset
like Purdue's not what you what he used
to be you know Brahmas bring this thing
back right
so there's some pride that goes on with
that but you know there's some truth to
it because you know our legacy is not a
you know we're not a you know football
powerhouse yet but we're going we're
coming I like your garage I like it all
right let's get into last last night's
game that two point conversion going
forward I mean Anthony Lin that was a
brilliant decision because if you if you
lose you're still the five seed if you
win man you've got a great shot at being
the 1 seed right there on the spot and
that's the key I think the the pros
outweigh the count they did so it was it
was easy choice you know now what they
were doing talking about the cans the
the Kansas City Chiefs secondary I have
no idea what was happening what I mean
they just had stacked bed net they
stacked it to the right no we call
closet because they're in close right so
they had two receivers to the to the
right hand side and they dismantled and
then now I think it's sensible I think
he was saying we're gonna play in and
out we call banjo and the receiver is
the defender the defenders in the
receivers just switched positions one
ran inside one around outside and both
the defenders went inside and that's
what happens when you get lack of
communication pre-snap they don't know
what you're doing and both guys stays on
a guy he I mean there wasn't a guy five
yards around him and they didn't it
didn't look I know Brock when you
thought it was a pick play I mean it
wasn't a pick so it didn't even it
wasn't like the the natural pick because
you know when you come into the new rule
in the league is that you can block one
yard down the field right and now when
you're on the one-yard I know we're on
the three yard line you can block on
least the one or the two ish get away
with it you can't really pick that guy
they don't even do that they just ran
her out well we just had your fellow
hall-of-famer LaDainian Tomlinson fellow
first ballot hall-of-famer LT on the
show and he says without Eric Barry this
defense is as pedestrian as it has been
all year long and that's gonna be their
problem what merit forward Eric wouldn't
have been there covering though right
those are two corners is a nickel in the
corner cover e now Eric did make some
plays though when he played in the first
half
Eric was flying around to the
all he made some tackles for losses he
did get some of the guys in position
he's a tremendous player and when he's
not in the air when you don't have a
leader I know Houston's up front but
when you don't have a leader on the back
end you don't make a lot of plays and
we've seen that throughout the whole
year with this with this football team
offensively they're exciting they put up
a lot of points they were even running
the ball last night and defensively they
just 32nd in the league for a reason
I know Chiefs fans are sitting there
saying oh here we go again
great start to a regular season mediocre
finish and then trap door opens in the
playoffs or mahomes is just such a game
changer he's gonna be the difference
maker what which one do you believe Ron
well when you have to and go back to
them playing Baltimore two weeks ago
you know it's fourth and 17 he has to
roll out to his right-hand side throw
the ball back across the field in the
middle of field which you should never
do you know and he's been doing it all
year and he's getting away with it and
then Tariq Hill comes in out of nowhere
and catches the ball when you got a
convert to plays like that on the
consistent basis week after week to win
that's not sustainable it's just not I
mean it looks great and we we have fun
with it but over the course of the year
and specially in the playoffs your
weaknesses come to the forefront in the
playoffs well you could also say it's
not sustainable to keep coming down from
double digits on the road like Philip
Rivers just did in Pittsburgh down 16
and then last night down 14 three
different times I mean that's not
sustainable either yeah I mean when
people talk about you know even though
they are saying the most balanced team
in the league right now might be the LA
Chargers almost at Sandy by the way I
almost I knew that whether your head
right there too it's so it's gonna check
it looks like they really should be in
San Diego but anyway they're here yes
they're playing good football they are
and I mean you know last night was
Melvin Gordon without Eckler without
Keenan Allen - and they were but Phillip
for East 37 he's he's slinging that rock
and that country boy I Love You Man I
love his feistiness I love everything
about him you know he can't run from
here to there in 20 seconds I mean he is
like I don't know I don't know if in
their prime if Dan Marino
or him or the slowest but they both can
throw the football
well it's met interesting rod Watson you
mentioned Moreno Kuzma Holmes could be
the youngest MVP since Marino's MVP
season because of the way that he's
lighting up when Chris Brockman gave the
update to the poll question just last
segment and it was mahomes Brees rivers
are girly for your MVP choice you said
from the Callaway corner I don't know
about Brees what do you mean by that and
the reason I said is because the last
two week has been pedestrian for Brees
and when you're the MVP it has to be
every week and this young kid is crazy
at it he's been throwing the football
extremely well all year long from week
one to now one of my arguments is I
think a lot of people should consider
Aaron Donna cuz Aaron doubt what he's
doing from the D tackle position what is
he doing tell me you know just you know
I don't know if he got any sexist past
week but before that he had 16 half
sacks
I mean tackles for losses the
quarterback pressures those things you
normally see from defensive ends but
deepens attackers where they get
double-team on a consistent basis he is
a beast inside and nobody's even talking
about him you won't see this again and
you'll see it again from him but on the
norm normally from the inside position
they don't get pressure like that he's
getting double-team constantly and he
wins and he's still putting those 330
pounds guards and centers right in the
lap quarterbacks nobody talks about him
and I know you know last time it
happened you know the only MVP that
happened for the league is LT he had 20
and a half sacks they had a really good
defense so maybe that rush defense some
of the lacking of you know they don't
they're not tremendously good at
stopping the run or the consistent basis
right that hurts him but what he's done
this year has been amazing Rod Woodson
here in the Rich Eisen show here's a
couple of stats of of mahomes that leaps
out about his MVP resume his 243 yards
passing last night fewest total in a
game from this year - 43 - 43 ok and he
has the highest passer rating in the
National Football League in losses
114 point 6 so it's not like the losses
come with him funkin right you know I
just was so tough
for me to wrap my arms around having
somebody that young in his first full
season be the MVP it's only one but it's
true it's only one game I could remember
that he cut out shot his team in the
foot and I was the New England game when
he threw the pick going into the then
the second half happened but the second
half happened but he's a tremendous
player you know all the things that he
does
you can't not put on a tape and go hey
quarterbacks I want you to look at this
because I want you to play like at right
no no it's very rare
he's inept and a lot of people have said
it and is so true he remind you of Favre
that he'll roll out of pocket he'll
sling in a throat any which way that he
wants to he remind you of Favre in that
regard too he had two left-handed throws
last night yeah - he will just make
these crazy throws that you don't think
anybody know look last but look I mean
exactly so there's the Favre
then there's the rolling out of the
pocket making throws against the grain
of the body that you don't expect coming
like Aaron Rodgers right and then
there's the play begins half the time
after he gets hit right of Ben
Roethlisberger yes it's kind of like all
rolled into one
millennial body it's kind of crazy but
City right now
faint happens though it catches up to
all players
it really does what do you mean what I
mean by that is though think about how
many touchdowns Brett Favre was thrown
for but thinking how to be interceptions
he's thrown true so it's a leader in he
was a leader in as a leader interception
that it still is the live he was in
touchdowns but that's you know so you
know you look at a young kid like this
doing so many great things and he has so
much confidence in his Army's throwing
the ball in these small windows if DB's
has turned their head which they don't
for some odd reason if the ball is right
by your head is by your ear oh you have
opportunities but you know one thing I
do say he's exciting to watch he's fun
to watch is it sustainable for this year
it is and he's played well and I think
he is by far the MVP candidate should
win it because he's played lights out
from week one all the way through and
we'll see what happens in Seattle next
week and if he like
sit up there then I think he wraps up
the MVP if not the bye week for the
Chiefs and that could be just again just
uh you know ten days away we'll see how
it all plays out Rod Woodson here on the
Rich Eisen show all right let's talk
Steelers Ron Oh what in the world
happened with Roethlisberger last week
with the ribs well I'm listening to my
I'm listening to Mike Mike said that he
he got a shot and the shot had to sink
in so to speak and get into the ribs
that take the pain away I believe Mike
you know I Balat of people that's
talking about Mike Thomas I think that
is crazy
well I say here all the time Mike if you
wanna if Steeler Nation finally wants to
bounce him guess what he you know
speaking on behalf of every other team
that's gonna be hiring a new coach he
will be good thank you okay so I will
say that but it was just bizarre and
strange and the fact that they didn't
say that after the game that yes you
know hey they need a shot and it had a
sink in instead it was well there was a
flow and and and then we find out from
Big Ben and and and and Mike Tomlin that
the equipment is old and they didn't
really get a good read on things it's
just it was just a bizarre explanation
and how it came out in dribs and drabs
makes you think there is something else
well known there first of all there's no
problem with darauf
with the offense the offense is they put
up points they put up 21 they still lost
it's the defense and it's that's been
the issue for several years now it's
like somewhere along the line the
defense has to be adaptable
we can't always say what we do what we
do hmm now go back to San Diego and they
put Keenan on at number three and we
just kept lying about you just kept a
linebacker there over and over and over
so the linebacker has to cover the best
route running receiver in the National
Football League that's crazy
and you never make an adjustment and you
just you turn back around go what we do
what we do right that you can't say that
you have to be a depth if you want to
win you have they're gonna take
advantage of your defense you have to
change something well who's that on
that's one Keith Butler he's a DC I know
Mike has a DC background and there is
some he has some you know his
fingerprints on some of the defense cuz
they do play Tampa
the Tampa 2 now they play more I play a
lot of two-man or cover 5 which is when
the corners and the Nichols are playing
underneath the receivers and you got a 2
2 man shell on top they do that a lot
more than a preview has done it in the
past but let's keep Butler and you just
you have to say if they're putting in
Keenan Allen there I have to make an
adjustment I go man-to-man and I put a
like body on him you can't tell me it's
third and four it's a critical situation
you have to get to stop to get the ball
back for your offense to try to go back
down to score and you put your
linebacker on him again all they did was
clear out the two receivers on the left
right hand side Kaylin hesitated and ran
it out that was the easiest turn on
conversion that Philip Rivers had all
year well we had again LaDainian
Tomlinson on last our Rod Woodson and he
said that if Pittsburgh doesn't adjust
on defense against New England oh
absolutely because they always allow all
the underneath and that's where Edelman
and Gronk just have a feast that if they
don't change they're gonna get beat I
can't you're right rich he's absolutely
right that I can't remember what year
they beat New England the Steelers did
but that year they played man-to-man
they came in and said we're not giving
you all this underneath stuff we're not
gonna sit back in these zones let your
receivers just play isolation against
our linebackers we're gonna get in your
faces we're gonna play man-to-man you
don't have any real fast receivers so go
play man-to-man and get after the
quarterback that's what you have to do
at Tom you don't do that to Tom Brady
that's that's not even funny I mean he's
gonna pick you apart and so if they
don't make that adjustment with Tom in
this game it's gonna be a long and if
they lose you gotta remember what
Baltimore's doing and they have the
Saints next week I said talk about the
Steelers yes and they finish up with the
Bengals which is not a give me it's a
divisional game well excuse me don't
sleep on the Cleveland Browns also
Roderick when they are playing it would
Baltimore this is a huge game Cleveland
in Denver yes let's just say Baker
Mayfield is in fact the unluckiest lock
of the week is I already put my MA
dangerous he wakes up dangerous every
day he wakes up dangerous in Denver
which by the way with altitude is
particularly dangerous yes so although I
don't know if there's any scientific
empirical evidence to back up that winds
that one then home for Cincinnati which
I know he's not a gimme but there's huge
axe in there and they I think they would
like to give him the Heisman again at
the 50-yard line with the dog pound in
full growth and then they're at
Baltimore yes and we saw an Ohio
quarterback make a throw in week 17 in
that building that made him the folk
hero of western New York if you recall
that's how things ended yes don't sleep
on the Cleveland Browns is what I'm
saying Ron you know what I don't listen
that number six spot right now for the
wild card I'm for Graham it's up for
grabs
it really is that's a lot of work that
they still have to do and they have to
hope that the other team in front of
them lose so that's a good wish list it
really is I don't know if that's gonna
happen now they can't be I don't know if
they can beat Denver even though their
defense especially without you don't
have your top corner mmm you know they
do have a running game and and the
little fella you know I give him a hard
time I talked about Baker Mayfield but
he plays well he has that dog inning
short instead if he's your guy you love
it yeah if you play against him are you
absolutely hating don't you want that
guy you do is that guy on your team oh
man we had multiple guys like you know I
mean you know Greg Lloyd was look you
know people love to hate Greg Louie he
had a disposition that was like no oven
he woke up dangerous he woke up really
dangerous wake up's for him but you know
you want that type of player on your
team you want that that guy that has
that that crazed dog in him but it's
tame and he knows how to play with that
you know he does a really good job of
getting in and out of the pocket looking
down the field he knows when to run when
to throw he's come in playing well as a
young young player and you know
hopefully I think he can sustain it they
got a lot of young talent in Cleveland I
sure do
they really do now they got to see if
they is Greg the head coach
is he gonna be that guy it's a lot up in
the air but right now in the next three
weeks all I'm saying is do not sleep on
the Browns a couple more minutes left
with Rod Woodson here perfect guy to ask
this question you played on that Ravens
defense that so many people think is the
greatest of all time
I would agree for a year okay a best
defense in the national football league
right now bears or Cowboys who do you
choose well that's a tough one I'm gonna
take the Bears because they get the ball
they cause havoc already they make it
tough on quarterbacks they do have
issues at times getting gashed in a
running game but they get turnovers I
mean III think they had like they have
like 30-something turnovers comparable
to I think the Cowboys at one point only
had ten they might be at fifteen age 16
age 17s right now they just don't turn
the ball over like the Bears and when
you turn the ball off and give you're
off into short field it's a lot easier
to score in the National Football League
and the way they do it is very similar
to kind of like Dallas they don't blitz
a whole bunch I don't have to you know
now but on the backend for the Bears
they get the ball I mean Eddie Jackson
didn't think he was gonna be getting
pick sixes like that and he's gotten to
this year a MOS who was a corner at Penn
State becomes a free safety he's playing
well fuller always been inconsistent
he is getting picks crazy he's just
believing in what he see he and and all
these guys in the back end they
understand one thing their front four
are gonna get a pass rush so they're not
gonna get double moved they can put
their footing around and go get it so I
think it's the Bears those guys have
played really well but you have to think
twice about it
I really take this myth in van der Essen
those front four I love Jaylon Smith
he's from my hometown Fort Wayne Indiana
even though he went to Notre Dame but
those guys can run and what they did
they opened everybody eyes when they
played against the Saints they did I
mean people knew about him already in
the football world but everybody on the
globe know how good they are now and
Byron Jones is really good too that kid
can cover he is he's you know he's
Connecticut guy who
had all the measurables at the alibi
have a great day in Indiana - he did he
had a great day he's playing well you
know I think rod hasn't playing well
those guys are playing really good
football they're playing fast ok good to
see you rod always good thanks for
coming in here Rod Woodson one of the
produce Boilermaker finest who through
Drew Brees under the bus I love you
boiler boiler on boiler violence right I
love you count there that happened all
right good to see rod sending you up the
up the 405 to NFL Network catch him on
NFL Total Access tonight at 7:00 Eastern
by the way that f4 mentioned Browns
Broncos game is on NFL Network on
Saturday night at 8:20 p.m. Eastern
after the Texans and the Jets and then
you on West would want to have Sunday
Night Football
I guess I see what Nick Foles is gonna
do I know right I know does he bring
back the magic actually can you stay one
more second yeah let's do it all right
Rod Woodson one more segment with rod
when we come back you mentioned Nick
Foles as we went to break and I'm like
you know let's stick around let's rod
spent a couple minutes on what do you
think the Eagles are gonna do with Nick
Foles because they could run it back
right they could the dog masks and see
how it goes or they have the same team
that's well the back end on the
defensive side they're banged up and
beat up their defenses on the back end
is not making the plays that it did last
year but then all the special plays that
they did a year ago an offense it's not
working either right so is Nick Foles
that guy that brings the little magic
touch back this think of eight this
thing they come out here I know it's a
big if but if they come out here they
beat the Rams
they win their final two games there's
gonna be some big question marks in
Philly like who should be the starting
quarterback
I'm not amazing you know and if they
kept they kept him on the roster and
taking the money for one reason for this
possibility well let's put up the NFC
playoff picture for two reasons one
because it's really fascinating - I
can't wait to get rods reaction on how
we're referring to the teams that are in
the hunt here on the ridge eyes and show
it's closed Vikings at six six and one
then you've got three teams at six and
seven Panthers Eagles and Redskins the
Packers are five seven and one and you
could see there in the division leaders
Saints Rams Bears Cal
it's wildcard leader Seahawks and
Vikings you want to read off the other
category and we don't say in the hunt
here do you see that you're sniffing oh
it's pretty funny cuz we used to call I
position that the receiver would come in
and it'd be right off the tackle we call
that a sniffing position the sniff
position there's what why do you call it
that no reason but I'm not gonna say it
on air but but look at that I mean the
Eagles are right there they are they're
happy mouth I just think this think just
I mean this a big if they come out here
beat the Rams which is a big if but then
they win their final two games and say
they they get that sixth spot yep you're
gonna tell me in Philly they're not
gonna be arguing about and talking about
who should be the starting quarterback
from now on well Philly Jill just argue
anyway but yes I see what you're saying
I've got another one though for you
who's that
Packers beat the Bears throw the records
out we all know Packers have the same
team it's just different coach right now
i Rodgers I'm just saying but on some
points they do that then they beat the
Jets then they go home and finish out
the season to finish eight seven and one
as Green Bay is home against Jack
Detroit yeah
Minnesota drops one as we all know it's
entirely possible they've got Miami they
may not answer at home for Chicago did
they get a treat like a is there like a
return policy on giving that guaranteed
money out to the quarterback oh do you
think they kept the receipt I know they
wish the hit oh my gosh good to see you
rod it's good to see you what do you
think of it we don't stay in the hunt
here sniffing it what I like sniffing it
you do I do
that's a great know what sniffing is
though well again we're just we're
sniffing we smell the playoffs yes
you're sniffing it yeah the aroma the
aroma of the playoffs is around there
and you're like been in the kitchen
now you got it I like it yes I like its
try it on for size it take that back to
the NFL Network how am I gonna do that
because you're gonna get there before I
will thanks for coming here run that's
Rod Woodson when we come back the news
update from Philly and Jeffrey Ross and
Dave Attell in person the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience